identify the hypothesis and conclusion
of the following statement and determine
whether the statement is always
sometimes or never true and the
statement here is the absolute value of
X is greater than zero for all real
numbers X now if I want to decide what
the hypothesis and conclusion is here
it's usually a lot easier to figure them
out if you rewrite this statement this
exact statement as an if-then statement
so this what this statement is saying is
if X is a real number then the absolute
value of X is greater than zero so let
me rewrite that if if X is a real number
real number then then the absolute value
of x is greater than zero these are
equivalent statements now when you write
it like this it's much easier to
identify the hypothesis and the
conclusion the hypothesis you can view
it as it's the if part of this
proposition so this right here is the
hypothesis X is a real number that is
the hypothesis hypothesis and the
conclusion is the then part sometimes
it's called the consequent it's this
part right here no not it's this part X
absolute value of X is greater than zero
this is the conclusion conclusion or the
consequent and over here if you wanted
to circle them this is the conclusion
that is the conclusion and the
hypothesis is for all real numbers it's
a little bit easier to identify when you
see it written like this this is the
hypothesis now I don't want you this you
get confused with the idea of a
scientific hypothesis which is related
but a little bit different a scientific
hypothesis is an explanation for some
phenomena that can be tested so a
scientific a scientific hypothesis might
be something like saying blueberries
which I'm writing in blue intentionally
blueberries help reduce the risk of
cancer reduce the risk of cancer this
right here is a scientific hypothesis
you could then go feed a bunch of people
blueberries for
long period of time and see if they have
a less likelihood of developing cancer
than people who never got blueberries
and everything else is equal and so it
would be testable you could see if it's
true and the conclusion would be whether
this is true or not this is but this is
in the scientific hypothesis world not
to be confused with the notion of
hypothesis we're using right now I don't
want to confuse you too much I'm just
going to leave this on the side here but
when you're in algebra 1 and especially
you know these are according to the
California Standards the hypothesis in
this context is the antecedent of this
proposition or it's the if part of this
proposition now the more interesting
question is whether it is true I mean we
can sit in label statements all day but
that's not interesting the more
fundamental thing is is this a true
statement is it true that if X is a real
number then the absolute value of X is
greater than 0 well the one number that
pops out of my mind that disproves this
is if X is 0 0 is a real number 0 is a
real number that's true but all right
but in caps but the absolute value of 0
is equal to 0 it's not greater than 0 so
this disproves this statement it's
definitely not always true it's
definitely not always true now if you
pretty much have any other real number
this will be true because any other real
number is some distance away from 0
that's what the absolute value measures
so if you took a 1 or a negative 1 or
whatever the absolute value of those are
greater than 0 so this is sometimes true
this is sometimes true